well I do believe that the land
rightfully belongs to the Jews I do not
think the moral obligation is sufficient
reasoning to intervene in this conflict
as libertarians non-interventionism is a
key tenant of the philosophy why should
we continue funding anything in the
Middle East even Israel given our track
record and why is intervention on
judeo-christian moral grounds
permissible although we have a
separation of church and state okay so
it's not intervention on the basis of
judeo-christian morality per se
meaning if it were just on the basis of
judeo-christian morality then we would
not be giving aid to any of the of the
other countries in the Middle East for
example we give it a decider Arabia
would give aid to Egypt we've a de
Jordan we give aid to the Palestinians
some three hundred four hundred million
dollars a year I'd be by the way I'd be
much happier if we just cut off all aid
I mean if like I think there's a strong
there's a strong case to be made the
Rand Paul case they just don't give
foreign aid period but if you do get
foreign aid then the idea is that it's
supposed to be in our national interests
then the question becomes is it in our
national interest to be involved in the
Middle East and this is a question I
think that was decided relatively
conclusively on September 11th I mean
the idea that we can sort of retreat
from the world and that we can just
intervene in sort of policing actions as
the Clinton administration did came home
on 9/11 and 3,000 Americans died because
of that
so the idea that a powerful America in
the world is unnecessary that we can
retract within our own borders and that
there won't be some enemy that comes and
fills the space by the way that does
have impact on Commerce that does have
impact on our economics it does have
impact on how people live now my view is
sort of the view of the founding fathers
which is that there that we ought not be
entangled in permanent alliances we
should always be looking to what is in
our interest but one of the things that
defines our interest is the fact that we
are a good country right we are we are
great because we are good is the idea
that if we were to be a completely
amoral country then we would not be
worth standing for right we should be to
the best of our ability balancing moral
obligations that we have is the leader
of the world in which capacity we've
liberated Europe twice and in which
capacity we've liberated the people of
the Soviet Union then in which capacity
we have liberated the people of South
Korea now all of those things are great
goods I think it's one of the reasons
why the United States is the beacon of
the world and why it's something worth
defending
not just on power grounds so it but on a
realism level if we don't make more
allies than we have more enemies if we
don't
our allies and those allies are likely
to suffer catastrophic defeat if we
don't side with the countries that side
with us then we are likely to see those
those countries side with somebody else
and that puts us in a negative
international position with regard to
issues that a lot of the Rotarians do
care more about then defense things like
trade economics and an even culture